bonjour et bienvenue dans cette science
qui sera aujourd'hui consacré à une
critique de l'un des chefs-d'oeuvre de
steven spielberg est certainement l'un
des meilleurs thrillers scientifiques
réalisées jusqu'à présent
jurassic park
j'ai un site parc a été réalisé sous la
houlette d'un grand paléontologues
américains ne célèbre jack horner et par
conséquent ce film constitue une vitrine
de premier plan pour cette noble science
qu'est la paléontologie et une mine
d'informations sur les dinosaures pour
bon nombre d'entre nous c'est par
exemple dans jurassic park qu'on a
appris que les dinosaures plus de choses
en commun avec les oiseaux qu'avec les
reptiles
cathy lights on va courir à 40 km heure
que les dinosaures avaient le sang chaud
et calvin heather ça pouvait être pire
malheureusement c'est aussi là qu'on
nous a vendu que le t-rex ne voyait pas
les choses
immobile et nenê aurait n'y fait pas non
plus apparemment c'est aussi là qu'on
nous a appris que le dit le faisant
cracher du venin mais soyons honnêtes
ces deux derniers points ne sont que
fantaisie par contre ce qui est
clairement en fout c'est la façon on
mange les brachiosaures et non vous ne
rêvez pas il mâche leur nourriture et
même mieux que ça il rumine
voici la mâchoire d'un ruminant elle
porte des molaires le mollet revient de
la même racine que le mot meules
cela veut dire que ce sont des dents
fait pour broyer des fibres végétales et
massy la donne à breaker qui n'est pas
plus grosse qu'un petit doigt il n'y a
vraiment pas de quoi faire une meule ça
c'est parce que tu sais comment je peux
me servir de mon petit doigt
en revanche les dans de brefs lazare à
disposition une mâchoire forme d'un
excellent peigne idéal pour effeuiller
les branches d'arbres mais certainement
pas fait pour mâcher mais alors comment
ma chère et il me demandez-vous
et bien comme des oiseaux en avalant des
cailloux qui vont broyer la nourriture
dans leur résilié et ça ce n'est pas une
invention puisqu'on a retrouvé ses
pierres polies par les sikhs digestive
dans la cage thoracique de nombreux
dinosaures
autre erreur et elle est de taille en
entrant dans le hall d'accueil de
jurassic park
on découvre une reconstitution d'un
combat épique entre un t-rex et un
diplodocus
or diplodocus etirex non pas du tout
vécu à la même époque
plus de 80 me
condamner les séparent pour la vous vous
dites certainement conquis nay
on n'est pas aux millions d'années près
mes rendez vous contre 80 millions
d'années c'est presque 20 millions
d'années de plus que ce qu'il ne sait
pas du direct si ça c'est du pinaillage
alors autant dire que le t-rex est
encore parmi nous sans revient
exactement au même
de manière plus générale ce mélange de
dinosaures étaient là ce courant dans
les films et dessins animés et
popularisé l'idée que tous les deals
arrivé en même temps au même endroit ce
qui est faux ben oui pourquoi croyez
vous que les paléontologues se sont
embêtés à diviser le règne des
dinosaures en trois périodes le trias le
jurassique et le stress et la grc
crétacé c'est parce que chaque période a
vu naître s'épanouir à disparaître une
faune de dinosaures entre autres très
très très très très très différentes et
dinosaures du trias généralement petits
n'ont rien à voir avec ceux du
jurassique comprenant laisseront pas de
géant au long cours et le stégosaure et
ils sont eux mêmes très différent des
dinosaures du crétacé la période où ont
vécu les ankylose or véritable char
d'assaut vivant le tricératops et le
célèbre tyrannosaure et pour ça on
retrouve exactement la même erreur que
dans le jurassic park en regardant le
petit dinosaure de denver dans ce film
petit kg et la pataugeoire et pointu le
stégosaure tous les deux du jurassique
fréquentes sert à la triade ses dents
tranchantes le tyrannosaure e du crétacé
et que dire de dinosaures de disney dans
lequel des dinosaures d'à peu près
toutes les époques et de tous les
continents côtoient longy squames à un
reptile apparu 15 millions d'années
avant le tout premier dinosaure
ils sont aussi en compagnie de primates
lémuriens et en plus les dinosaures
yb route de l'herbe ah oui parce qu'en
fait les dinosaures
sauf les oiseaux n'ont jamais posé le
moindre brin d'herbe et donc l'herbe est
apparue entre 20 et 30 millions d'années
après la fin du règne des dinosaures
donc dire qu'un dinosaure herbivore est
un abus de langage
on devrait plutôt dire si ta vie j'ai
désormais fabriquer tous
et on ne vous parle même pas de king
kong ou de l'âge de glace qui font se
côtoyer des espèces éteintes de toutes
les époques et de tous les pays ainsi
que des films 10000 de roland emmerich
ouais mais bon enfin bon ce film comment
dire enfin comment dirais je vois la
bombasse et c'est vraiment un gros tas
de merde
merci yann ces mots que je cherchais
toutes ces erreurs
c'est à se demander s'ils sont bien
sérieux ces savants de films de science
fiction
ben justement à ce sujet il ne me semble
pas très au fait de trois petites
notions de biologie élémentaire par
exemple dans le laboratoire de jurassic
park le professeur vous explique comment
il fait pour que les dinosaures ne se
reproduise et bien parce que tous les
animaux à jurassic park sans les
femelles maicon ne le voit pas de cet
oeil là mais win ce démon tard vous
assignez qu'un groupe composé
exclusivement d'animaux femelle peut se
reproduire
non non non merci et si monsieur une
femelle peut se reproduire sans mal
on appelle cela la parthénogenèse c'est
un mode de reproduction où les femelles
donnent naissance seule à d'autres
femelles sans avoir besoin de les deux
normales il permet de ne pas s'encombrer
d'un macho qui prendrait place et il est
assez grand pour qu'on le retrouve par
exemple chez des sauterelles comme la
magicienne danger qu'il y en france et
le lézard à speedo celis unis par anis
et il y aurait même un cas documentés
chez l'homme
bref on se demande si monsieur hammond a
bien choisi son équipe
j'ai dépensé sans compter le pompon est
atteint quand on réfléchit un peu à la
manière dont ils ont pu déterminer
qu'ils étaient bien face à des
dinosaures
qu'est ce que tu veux dire ben regarde
le velociraptor qui te dis que c'est un
vrai velociraptor ah mais oui je sais ça
on j'en ai déjà entendu parler en fait
les velociraptor de jurassic park
ils sont beaucoup trop grands pour être
des brevets l'oci raptor est en fait ce
sont maintenant ça c'est bon c'est du
pillage
ce que je veux dire c'est que monsieur
adn nous explique dans le film que les
savants de jurassic park sont censés
avoir utilisé en majorité de l'adn de
grenouilles pour un créer des dinosaures
ce qui fait leur velociraptor des
grenouilles dagois ressemblante à des
velociraptor certes en gros pour faire
simple le fossile là c'est un dinosaure
dans la cocotte en dessous c'est à
dinosaures mais ça ce sont des
batraciens d'abus aux bâillements
dinosaur yens si leur code génétique et
celui une grenouille comment pourrait-il
s'agir d' authentiques dinosaures comme
il en a existé il ya des millions
d'années de cela il ne suffit pas de
ressembler à un dinosaure pour en être
de même qu'il y à des dinosaures qui ne
ressemble pas tout à fait à notre idéal
dinosauriens cette pirouette
scénaristique permet en tout cas de
justifier pourquoi la peau des dinos de
jurassic tard qu'ils étaient gagneuse et
gluante plutôt comprimé eh oui en 1993
déjà on connaissait des dinosaures à
plumes depuis presque cent ans comme
l'archaeopteryx par exemple et l'idée
des dinosaures en plus mais avait déjà
fait un bout de chemin dans les milieux
autorisés donc l'adn de batraciens c'est
bien pratique pour justifier l'absence
de plumes c'est d'ailleurs été un peu
corrigé dans le troisième volet de la
série
venons en maintenant au coeur du film à
savoir la résurrection de dinosaures ou
d extinction est elle vraiment possible
dans les films les scientifiques
utilisent le sens contenues dans des
moustiques fossiles et les gants de
landreau est vieux de plusieurs millions
d'années mais un insecte fossilise dans
l'ombre n'est plus que l'ombre de lui
même
en fait il n'est plus qu'une bulle de
lui-même et oui car le moustique piégé
dans la résine durci meurt rapidement et
alors tout un tas de bactéries qui sont
restés piégés en même temps que lui le
dévore finalement il ne reste plus du
moustique que son empreinte fidèlement
préserver en trois dimensions dans
l'ombre mais est totalement vide peu de
moustiques plus de sens plus rien du
tout ce qui est drôle c'est que dans le
jurassic park il ya aussi des plantes
qui ont été ramenés à la vie d'anne
s'est inquiété de viry forman a disparu
depuis le crétacé enfin je veux dire
c'est cette plante là j'aimerais bien
savoir quelle mouche l'a piqué est ce
vraiment possible de ramener une espèce
est apte à la vie pour les espèces
éteintes depuis suffisamment peu de
temps comme le dodo le mastodonte
america ou encore le mammouth dont la
date d'extinction n'excède pas quelques
milliers d'années
cela reste encore envisageable dans les
caddies madrid par exemple on peut
espérer retrouver une cellule
naturellement préservé dans la glace
dans ce cas il n'y aurait qu'à implanté
le noyau de cette cellule dans une
cellule embryonnaire d'une espèce proche
un embryon d'éléphants par exemple qu'on
aurait préalablement débarrasser de son
propre noyau est sixième le tout est le
noyau de mammouth retombe en enfance et
commande l'embryon pour qu'il donne le
petit mammouth ont évidemment sur le
papier ça y'a simple mais c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire
les cellules préserver dans la glace de
sibérie sont mortes depuis plus de dix
mille ans tout de même
on a déjà parlé ici à maintenir en vie
puis de quelques années la brebis clonée
dolly alors imaginez un mammouth
et puis même si on parvenait à le faire
ce mammoth aurait un système immunitaire
vieux de plus de dix mille ans une
époque où les maladies était sûrement
très différente de celle d'aujourd'hui
pire encore ces globules blancs d'un
autre âge risquerait de laisser passer
des maladies dont on croyait cette
débarrasser depuis longtemps ce mammouth
on deviendrait une vraie bombe
bactériologique
enfin quel serait l'avenir de ce
mammouth ont ramené
être parqués dans un an être disséquée
par les scientifiques être élevés en
batterie pour être servies dans des
banquiers huppé pourquoi pas encore plus
de questions se posent quant il s'agit
de ramener à la vie une espèce d'homme
comme l'homme de néandertal nous autres
homo sapiens avons déjà du mal à tolérer
l'existence de nos semblables quand ils
sont d'une couleur de peau ou d'une
religion différente
imaginez ce qui se poseraient avec un
homme d'une autre espèce
finalement pour une plante imaginer
qu'il soit toxique ou invasive
de toute façon pour les dinos la réponse
est très claire ils sont beaucoup trop
vieux ils n'ont pas vécu il ya quelques
milliers mais il ya plusieurs millions
d'années
de plus il n'y avait pas de glace aux
pôles lors de leur règne donc il n'y a
presque aucune chance qu'on en retrouve
des cellules entière préserver c'est
dommage j'aurais bien voulu voir un
dinosaure en vrai oh mais tu aurais tous
les jours des vrais dinosaures
oui je sais bien mais ce dinosaure là
qu'ils sont si différents de ce que
j'imaginais
ce peut-être que ce que tu avais imaginé
est très loin de ce qui a pu être vrai
et grâce sur toi on sait comment faire
repousser des dents chez les poules et
on sait aussi que la queue bestial chez
les oiseaux adultes est très développée
chez les embryons à mais alors il
suffirait de peu de choses pour que
peut-être un jour les généticiens réveil
des jeunes endormi depuis des millions
d'années et fasse en quelque sorte
d'évoluer un oiseau en poule et au sort
oui et l'équipe de jack horner travaille
justement très sérieusement dessus à et
alors là nous verrions ce à quoi les
dinosaures pouvait réellement ressembler
ce stage s'est terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi pour en savoir plus sur la d
extinction est ce qu'il peut être
réellement fait avec de l'adn ancien
nous vous conseillons la lecture du
livre nantis jurassic park ainsi que la
lecture des articles dédiés à cette
thématique serait dit nos blogs passeur
de sciences et sciences et avenir dont
les biens sont dans la description et
pour tout savoir de la biologie des
dinosaures nous
et ont l'excellente terreau d'alkyle
rose et enfin évidemment n'oubliez pas
de voir le film merci à tous
bonjour je suis un parisien
vous vous demandez certainement pourquoi
nous n'avons pas parlé de dinosaur king
et bien tout simplement parce que c'est
un gros un peu un texte pour faire ce
combat très diminué de 16,3